ORI KASHI: Welcome.
My name is Ori Kashi,
and I'm a product manager
on the Cloud SQL team.
In this video, I'll show you
how to create, run, and manage
SQL instances using
Google Cloud SQL.
Cloud SQL helps manage
mundane administrative tasks
for MySQL, Postgre, and
Microsoft SQL Server
databases so you can
focus on what matters.
Let's walk through how to create
a SQL Server database on Cloud
SQL and connect to it from
SQL Server Management Studio.
You can set up an instance
in just a few steps.
Let's go through
the basics, and I'll
point out some options for
additional configuration
along the way.
We'll start by navigating to
Cloud SQL in the GCP console
and clicking Create Instance.
This instance will
be created in the US,
and we'll leave
the zone set to any
so Cloud SQL can choose for us.
Now let's take a look at
our configuration options.
You can specify your
addition, the instance size,
high availability, and more.
For this demo, I'll stick
with Standard Edition,
and I'll choose a four
core high memory instance.
Maximizing memory is a
good choice for SQL Server
because it can take
advantage of the extra memory
for performance.
That said, don't worry too
much about initial sizing.
You can scale the
instance up or down later.
Let's increase the storage
capacity to 200 gigabytes
because increasing disk capacity
also increases performance.
Check out the performance
calculator on the right.
As I add capacity,
my disk performance
increases, which
allows my database
to process more
operations per second.
I'll leave Automatic
Storage increases
enabled so that I
don't accidentally
run out of disk space.
Lastly, let's ensure that the
database will automatically
provide isolation from failures.
We can do that by enabling
the high availability
configuration,
which for SQL Server
adds a standby instance
in a different zone.
Now that we're happy with the
configuration of our instance,
let's kick off the creation.
It may take a few minutes
for your instance to create.
This is a great time to
grab a quick cup of coffee.
You can also check the
status of your instance
by navigating to
your instance list.
Once you see a green checkmark,
your instance is ready.
Looks like our instance
has finished creating.
Let's open the Details
page to continue.
There are many ways to
connect to this instance.
Within GCP, for
example, we could
use App Engine, Compute
Engine, or Container Engine,
but we could also connect
from just about anywhere
by authorizing IP addresses
or using the Cloud SQL proxy.
For this demo, I'll connect
using a familiar tool, SQL
Server Management Studio.
I'll be running SQL Server
Management Studio from a GCEVM,
and so I'm able to connect
securely and easily
via private IP.
Once I remote
desktop into my VM,
I'll start SSMS and then put in
the private IP of my Cloud SQL
instance.
I'm using the default
user SQL Server,
and then I enter our root
password from before.
And now we're connected,
so let's go ahead
and create and insert some data.
To begin, I'll
create a database.
Next, I'll insert some data.
Finally, let's make sure the
data is now in our database.
And it is.
Great.
So to recap, we just
created a Cloud SQL instance
with high performance
and high availability
and connected to it with SQL
Server Management Studio.
Now that you've seen how to
get started, give it a try.
You can learn more about Google
Cloud SQL and our free trial
program at
Cloud.Google.com/free.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]